guys hi oh hello oh are you okay CalPERS
has enough been known or seen about the
films that you have gotten work out of
it now yeah actually i'm currently
working on a project it's amazing how
many people come out of the woodwork the
girl like you know what I I'm an artist
for Emma writer and I I didn't think I
could do it and I gave up really glad
this happened because I had done that
and that's why i emailed we're going to
begin with III I needed to force myself
into doing the things that I really love
I sort of given up on a case I just
wasn't confident in my abilities and a
lot of people have come up to me and
said the same thing about what they do
and so I'm actually working on a comic
right now that's set it's about growing
up a geek in the Midwest my part started
Biograph that I'm working with a lot of
other artists and writers who are
unpublished or or published in doing
their own thing and you know we're
putting all that together it's sort of
like it's sort of like forced me to
really work and it's shown me that I can
actually do to achieve these things that
I guys like I really want to do
right
you say
oh never no not at all not at all I mean
like that's the thing first of all I
mean I mean there's there's a part of
like wanting you can throw a lot of
things you can dream but there you know
like I don't want to tell anyone that
they shouldn't reach for whatever lofty
goal they have because they think they
should it's just it's just the lesson
that I learned was that I always wanted
to draw superheroes I always want to I
love capes I love the whole thing i love
the entire genre but it doesn't fit my
style it really it really does i'm more
of a more of a loaf i sort of like
Adrienne toe mean kind of like artists
where I've artwork from photo reference
but I it's very like black and white
simple but but I means but more
realistic more detailed it doesn't fit
the it doesn't necessarily fit the
superhero genre and so I learned that
and I feel like i tempered my dream and
I and I and it helped me to focus
because I work focused on my strengths
instead of on chest the vague goal of
working on comics it gave me the ability
to realize what I needed to do to get to
my goals and I think that that I think
that's that's the real thing about
people that don't get their goals their
dreams achieves because they don't
really understand how to get to them but
I mean they can still happen you just
have to learn like what it is about you
that makes those those dreams a reality
Phil on your quest change the classic in
any way to be active
what you know um actually no they were
very very hands-off that kind of stuff
like I would have thought they were
something was more more choreographed
but it wasn't at all the only thing that
had changed was it motivated me in a way
that I hadn't been in a very very very
long time and it and it focused me and
it really just kind of good free and
they asked getting me to like really
really work really hard at you know
achieving the things that I need to and
so I think I think it grounded me but
also gave me more confidence to do
things that I never thought I would be
able to so other than that the story is
what it was that is what happened but
experience itself just made me believe
that I have a chance I think more than
anything else have actually a Columbia
is home to the true-false Jam festival
which is one of the largest documentary
contestants world and which was awesome
and so Morgan brought the movie to
Columbia which was really cool because
all the people that were in the movie
like like the tertiary word that came to
the viewing and we did a 40-minute QA
and everyone really loves to be a great
response and he had the bar that I work
at we had a big after party afterwards
and like in Morgan got to meet the owner
Sal and it was really really beside
taverin kind of got a lot of publicity
that idea was really great yeah it works
really well and everyone and that's what
he's got led me to work on this project
because when i was there all these
people would come up to me and be like
look no i didn't know you did this i do
this to like I've been looking for a
reason or an excuse to feel like myself
to work and I was like well let's let's
all do something together because we're
all there are a lot of talented people
columbia just imagine the rest of the
Midwest so we're working on a comic
about trust that about being in the
Midwest and what that that means to
other day and everyone's experiences
because just an experience in lobby in
the nation s the artist banksy his ideas
what she wants to do in the process
she's going to the others will do it and
it's so fun to sit around in the garage
and help her like yeah absolutely i am
legitimately right I almost didn't email
you know if los I was like that's not
something i'll ever get in it I was like
you know I know you know my story my
parents Corey he saw something like I
feel like there's a there is something
to it i've always felt that way that's
why I've always embraced me at ease
because my feet away my parents were in
general I was like this is something
really who I should do something with
this and and then I didn't we send in
our dish tape and I wish they took him
about a year to let me know I was in it
I didn't find out I was actually in the
movie with Iranians expelled Morgan's at
Comic Con last year and he showed the
trailer and he's like oh by the way
you're in the trailer I was like well
then answers that question so I was on
pins and needles for about a year but
and I went through a little bit of like
you know kind of depression or really
exuberant that I couldn't really hard to
balance out but he can win it when I
finally found out I was like nope my
life is completely different and I just
instantly felt it look validated and
though I would enter and space we
pykrete their dream climbing on the time
they realize just like this year you
know I was like no I belong doing this
this is what I need to be doing forever
so
you